it 15 you kill jobs so what's happening
is business is closed businesses reduce
staff and automate right and businesses
by reduce the hours of the employees
that they have what you can't measure
which is really what hurts economic
growth which was really kind of what the
book was trying to get to is the number
of restaurants that don't open because
you close that gap you no longer can
make it easy for people to make a profit
and take the risk of making an
investment any puzzler is best known as
the former head of cke restaurants the
parent company of fast food chains
Hardee's and Carl's jr. when he was
named CEO in 2000 the company was on the
verge of bankruptcy pleas'd are focused
his attention on improving the customer
experience improving the food quality
simplifying the menu and emphasizing
good service he launched a campaign to
improve the chains image starting with
this much-discussed
2005 ad featuring Paris Hilton ten years
later the company had quadrupled in
value
in 2010 he co-authored the book job
creation how it really works and why
government doesn't understand
last year Donald Trump nominated puzzler
as US Secretary of Labor his
confirmation was broadly contested by
progressive groups and he ultimately
withdrew his bid I sat down with him at
Freedom Fest the annual libertarian
conference in Las Vegas and reposed her
thanks for talking to Reason great to be
here Nick thank you you were nominated
for Labor Secretary and withdrew your
nomination what happened
well after Betsy DeVos went through such
a a litigious confirmation process
senators who had voted for her like
Susan Collins who from liberal states
were then inundated with emails phone
calls they they would go home and they
had protesters in their offices or you
know at their town halls people who had
never really seen protesters before
Schumer identified me as the target of
the left and and so they put a lot of
pressure that the the media was horrific
this fake news thing that Trump talks
about is so true and when you're a
nominee for the cabinet's you can't
defend yourself on TV well you have to
you know you just have to be clear you
can't tweet I think I said out a tweet
once thanking Jeb Bush for supporting me
and everybody came down on me like I'd
done something horrific so you can't
even defend yourself you've got to
depend on surrogates the that went on
for a longer period of time than it
should have because while the Press said
puzzler didn't file his ethics documents
there must be a problem the reality is I
was probably the first guy to file I
filed January 3rd but the office of
government ethics wouldn't respond so
for 6 or 7 weeks my document sat there
and you the Democrats wouldn't let the
committee wouldn't let them are eggs at
Alexander's committee scheduled a
hearing until they got something from
OGE on my ethics documents they let
Betsy DeVos go through without that but
me they wouldn't let go through so for
six weeks of the left got to beat up on
me Schumer identified me as their target
as I said and near the end some of the
more liberal Republicans got nervous and
when you don't have 50 votes you can't
win I got a call from vice president
pence telling me that
they that Mitch McConnell told him that
they had fallen I think a vote or two
below 50 you know we knew we never get
any more than 50 because there were two
who know they didn't vote for Betsy and
working to vote for me and and I said
look you know I'll withdraw I don't want
the president to have a a a failure on
the House the Senate floor that has my
name attached to it
I should just withdraw it he said well
let me see let me make sure that we
don't have it because we'd love you to
do this but let me just so he went in
checked it called me back a few other
things said look we're just it's gonna
be very very hard to get to 50 and I
said well I'm not gonna tilt at
windmills that's I'll just withdraw so I
would through the thesis of your book
which gets at a central issue of the
21st century economy which is job
creation how does it work and why
doesn't government understand it well
progressive don't get it don't get it
because that's not their objective their
objective isn't to create economic
growth or to create more jobs their
objective is to take what we have in
this country now and divide it more
equally they're not there no you don't
hear you know her Lizabeth Warren or
Bernie Sanders out there talking about
we need 3% GDP growth because they don't
really have policies that would generate
3% GDP growth we we advocated tax reform
a reduction of regulations better energy
policy and reduced spending so really
four of the five legs of the Trump the
Trump planer the fifth leg being and in
with respect to President Trump being
repealed and replacement of Obamacare or
health care reform so health care reform
wasn't as we didn't realize in 2010 what
a terrible effect that was going to have
on the economy or on everyday Americans
with premiums and deductibles going up
so we didn't cover that in the book but
we covered everything else and talked
about how what you really need to do to
generate job growth it's really not a
very complicated formula if you're
looking to invest if you're going to
take money you have and you're going to
invest it in a business there's a risk
the risk is you lose everything that you
invest so you want to go in with the
idea are going to get a good return
normally businesses look for about a 20
percent return but maybe 15 you would
invest because interest rates are so low
so if you put the money in bonds or
stocks maybe just get a 5 or 6 percent
return so if you can but if you can get
that 15 or
percent returned then your invest is
worth making the investment so when you
look to invest you look at two things
you look at what revenues your business
will generate in the location that
you're at let's take a restaurant for
example and you look at the costs of
running it and then you see if you're
going to make enough profit to give you
a return on that investment if revenues
come down because consumers don't have
money because either because they're of
tax policy their taxes are increased or
what's happened in the last few years is
they've got to pay these absorbent
insurance premiums and these very high
deductibles which takes money out of
people's pockets if you know that and
you're projecting out five years you're
going to project lower revenues on the
cost side if you if minimum wage is
going up and there's overtime regulation
coming in and your business taxes are
going up well then you're going to
project higher cost so if revenues are
down and costs are up then that your
your margin for making a profit sinks
considerably and you may not invest now
if you implement policies that reduce
taxes if you implement policies that
reduce regulation so that you're
increasing the revenues to the business
and you're decreasing the cost of
operating the business what you see is
not surprisingly economic growth
well workforce participation rates are
declining especially among men they have
actually kind of been grown or a pretty
level among women
the overall rate peaked in the overall
workforce participation rate peaked in
the late 1990s around 68 percent for men
it was almost 90 percent in the early
50s 90% of men were in the workforce
now it's down to about 70 it's under 70%
what's going on there because this is
it's longer than just the 21st century
which is seen historically low growth in
America you know why aren't more men
working and you know why aren't more men
in the labor market and you know if you
were Secretary of Labor and certainly as
a CEO of a fast food company you know
what where where are the men going that
they're not working well there's a
couple events the answer number one is
that you're talking about percentages of
people in the labor program so even if
the economy is growing the number of men
in the labor force can be increasing
even though the percentage is coming
down because as you know since the early
80s more women have been coming into the
labor force so as more women commit even
even if you're growing the number of men
you're still going to have a smaller
percentage
because more women are also coming in so
we've seen some of that we've also seen
now with people in my generation of the
baby boomer generation we've seen people
retiring but I think a more serious
problem is we've simply seen people
dropping out of the labor force because
they can't find good jobs there was a
real rash over the last eight years of
part-time jobs low wage jobs that were
created in the economy which is why you
see a push for things like minimum wage
increases or overtime ledges there try
what the Democrats are trying to do with
the progressive to try and do is since
they can't produce good-paying jobs
because they've done things that shrink
the potential for businesses to grow
shrink economic growth what they try and
do is take the jobs that aren't as good
paying the lesser paying lesser skilled
jobs and elevate those up which makes no
economic sense say you've got a job that
produces so much benefit you can't fit
you can't compensate people above that
limit so what you're seeing is people
dropping out of the labor force you met
Frank Larry Summers said that two of the
things that contribute to in Larry
Summers are you know left-wing
economists from Harvard but he's certain
he's a liberal side it was the Obama
made sure a whole lot more or less than
he is centered in any event even he said
unions unions contribute to unemployment
from and government benefits contribute
to unemployment I mean there you if it's
you know you do what's in your economic
best interest of your economic best
interest is to accept government
benefits rather than to work but you
because you can't find a good paying job
that's what you're going to do so
particularly in the in the fast-food
industry which are very well acquainted
with the push for you know of the fight
for 15 for a $15 minimum wage which in
many places would it would effectively
double the existing minimum wage what
you know from from the point of view of
somebody who ran a company that would be
directly affected by that what is the
effect of saying we're gonna double the
wages or we're going to go up by 50% of
the wages by government mandate that is
because we've over the past ten years
we've seen a lot of people saying well
you know what it actually it doesn't
have any effect or it might have a
positive effect but what what is your
experience about people that own
businesses yeah look the say number one
I I'm actually in favor of increasing
the minimum wage I'm in favor of
increasing it to the point where it
starts to kill entry-level jobs because
entry-level jobs are very important for
young Americans
cuz I started out at a baskin-robbins
thank God I had that opportunity but I'm
just to clear up all the fake press that
was out there I'm actually I've been
trying to convince the restaurant
industry in the franchise industry rep
rate groups to get behind increasing a
minimum wage but only to the point where
you didn't kill entry-level jobs fifteen
dollars I hope that mean I mean what
what should what would that be well the
Bureau of Labor Statistics about two
years ago came out with a excuse me the
Congressional Budget Office came out
with a study about two years ago that
said at nine dollars an hour
you'd lose about a hundred thousand jobs
nationally and $10 an hour you'd lose
five hundred thousand jobs so you know
five hundred thousand jobs is too much
now has that rubber moved in the last
ten years probably at but I need another
study to tell you but it can be
certainly be higher than seven and a
quarter
but at fifteen you kill jobs three
things three things could happen one is
businesses closed because they're no
longer profitable two is they reduce
labor either by cutting people's hours
or reducing their staff room or three as
they automate right and what we've seen
there are three recent studies there was
a duty in December of 2015 by the
Federal Reserve Board in San Francisco a
report out of the Federal Reserve Board
not a bastion of conservative economic
thought and they said in Crete they
looked at all the studies on minimum
wage included and concluded that
significant increases damage lesser
skilled workers the very workers is
supposed to help San Francisco went from
about a ten to eleven dollar minimum
wage up to thirteen Harvard Business
School came out with a report just a
couple months ago again not a bastion of
conservative economic thought Harvard
Business School that said every dollar
that the minimum wage that went up in
San Francisco there was a four to ten
percent increase in the closure of
restaurants so if you're going from ten
to fifteen that's a lot of restaurants
lastly Seattle Seattle went to thirteen
dollars up from ten and they'll
eventually go to fifteen event so we go
to fifteen like San Francisco University
of Washington again a left's a left
leading institution came out and said
that just going to thirteen had reduced
wages for low-skilled workers by nine
percent and deprived them of a hundred
and twenty five dollars a month they
can't afford that so what's happening is
business is closed
businesses reduce staff and automate
right and businesses by reduce the hours
of the employees that they have what you
can't measure which is really what hurts
economic growth which was really kind of
what the book was trying to get to is
the number of restaurants that don't
open because you close that gap you no
longer can make it easy for people to
make a profit and take the risk of
making an investment well we really
don't know us how many businesses didn't
open in those cities that would have
employed people so $15 an hour is a real
economic disaster but the point of it is
quite honestly the one progressives
promote this they're not out there
saying look this is going to help
economic growth or that there's going to
be more jobs what they're trying to do
is divide what exists more equally so
they're killing growth you know and that
University of Washington study actually
proves your earlier point that the
earlier increase in Seattle from I think
it was $9 to $10 or something like that
it did not have the negative light
effect so there is probably a threshold
over which you really go over the room
to do this but don't go nuts I mean if
your point is to help working-class
people to help less or skilled workers
to create entry-level jobs you can do
that wouldn't it be better and this is
from a pure policy place that you know
reason is a libertarian magazine I I
tend to believe that the best air you
know the proper minimum wage is zero you
know that it should be set by
individuals but that aside it's kind of
weird that you would cost that on to
businesses as opposed to saying as a
society we believe that people should
have a certain minimum level of income
why wouldn't taxpayers pay for that
through supplemental transfers to to
lower-income people yeah you know I
think that there is a very good system
for doing that the Earned Income Tax
Credit is is something I'm very
supportive of I think we had a 30% error
rate in payments though yeah that's like
many government programs well the core
issues the Kurd earned income tax credit
program is a subject to a lot of fraud
it's not very well put together but it's
lifted millions of people out of poverty
including young people and but more
importantly what what minimum wage
increases did and this is kind of a
hidden stories and I haven't talked
about it much but I have talked about it
the in our restaurants in Cali in
California when the minimum wage went to
$10 an hour and it's now going to 15 but
it went to ten I had dim
with our general managers as I often did
and and and district managers and if
they do eat at a Carl's jr. no well when
I had the dinners I would think it was
someplace super nice to show important
they were not that Carl's wasn't super
nice but they were there a lot in an out
burger right we'd go to Fleming's or
Morton's or something in any of it I
asked him what are the biggest problems
like what are you saying and uh and
virtually every one of them said people
coming to us and asking to have their
hours reduced I said why on earth would
people become at $10 an hour why would
people want to work less said they come
in and they say you know we're gonna
lose our Medicaid we're going to lose
our food stamps they're gonna lose our
section 8 housing law well you know
you've you've now created an economic
incentive for people not to work more on
earned income tax fixes that Earned
Income Tax that you do get a level you
do get a subsistence level but
everything you earn above that you don't
you never earn more than yours then you
then your your subsistence level
decreases so you're always met and then
at some point you earn enough that you
don't need the subsistence level and you
work your way out of welfare right now
we've got people if they call it the
welfare cliff you know you go over if
you go too far you go off the cliff but
we've got people trapped in a welfare
society because of things like the
minimum wage which quite honestly as I
said they left the progressives don't
intend to create jobs
you mentioned automation there's a lot
of chatter these days this you know it
recurs with regularity but that robots
are going to take our jobs Automation is
going to take our jobs our people right
to be worried about being displaced
permanently by automation yes and I want
to make it clear I got ad interview with
a with an I left the leftist magazine
called the Business Insider and they're
really like I should never have done the
interview but I got they asked me about
minimum wage and they said well why why
would somebody automate if the wage goes
up and I gave him the reasons and and I
said but there's also these other
reasons like that you know that you you
would you you want people because your
customers feel better dealing with them
you know it's better to build a culture
I mean there are a lot of reasons not to
automate to and of course they ran only
the favorable things I said about
automation and accused me of wanting to
completely automate all of
our restaurants which none of which I
you know the ultimate would be if you
had robot customers yes they would never
they would never get full right well you
mate with self-driving cars who knows
any way I can get humans out of the
prostitution business together and they
can get on with it yeah so so what I'm
gonna try and do is explain why people
automate this doesn't mean I think they
showed me right but they're going to
they're going to they're going to
automate because it reduced prices it's
more convenient you're going to have
self-driving cars right now you have
ordering kiosks and restaurants which
quite honestly while people my age might
not be as comfortable using although I'm
getting more comfortable you know my
kids that that's all they want to use I
mean they live off their iPhones you
know it's amazing I mean how quickly
this change is cut I think we're both
old enough to remember a pre kind of
barcode scanning checkout cashier you
know a supermarket and when that was
brought in people were oh my god this is
the end of employment in supermarkets
because you don't need that and
obviously it doesn't quite work that way
it doesn't and I and I do think there's
a threat to the current economy there's
a threat to people we really were not
training people for the jobs that exist
there are six million job openings right
now according to BLS the Bureau of Labor
Statistics that's a historic high
there's never been six million job
openings well why then is labor
participation so alone well the reason
is because people aren't trained for
those jobs there are jobs in computer
program there's jobs for welders there
job for construction workers there are
jobs out there that people aren't
getting the training for or don't want
there's a stigma to some manufacturing
jobs although now they become very
sophisticated jobs when I was a kid you
could probably be productive in a plant
in about a week you know an allocation a
month even fair when the men's room is
there know how to work the machines so
if the world's changed we need
apprenticeship programs we need
internships we need the kinds of things
that President Trump is promoting to get
these people trained for the jobs that
exist if we can continue to train people
for the jobs that exist I think we can
deal with a lot less you're going to
need people who fix those robots you're
going to need people that design them
you're going to need people that program
them I can tell you I don't know I'm
sure you have a computer how many times
does it break down and you wish there
was a guy in your house who could tell
you what to do with your computer sadly
I am that kind yeah me too but it so you
got but you go in these restaurants and
these are complicated pieces of
machinery and they are abused
right you know customers are you know
they're they're the were customers I
just wish they would go away they spill
sodas on him they do it you know I mean
it's all kind well you know our workers
worse than they used to be because
there's definitely training and you
talked about apprenticeship you talked
about stigmas you know it's in in the
abstract and even Donald Trump talks
about bringing back manufacturing jobs
everybody likes man you know factory
jobs are so nice they're not the ones
you know pouring steel or something like
that but you know or we're not training
people for jobs that exist but or is
there a larger culture of work that is
Minh say under attack but has gone
missing where people understand that
working is more than you know being
given a job and then being given a
paycheck I mean I and I guess my short
answer is our American workers worse
than they used to be I don't think so I
think the jobs are more complicated I
think you know back at the you know
following from the from the end of the
civil war up until the 1920s or 30s you
had a huge influx of immigrants coming
here for these high-paying factory type
jobs where you could go and work on an
assembly line you're doing the same
thing all day it's a low-skilled job but
it was good paying well those
low-skilled good-paying jobs are now
being done by machinery if you want to
work in a manufacturing plant now you've
got to have some skills so all we need
to do is train people so they have I
don't think it's that the labor force is
worse I think it's the labor force needs
to be better trained for the jobs that
exist what would you as if you were a
labor secretary what are what are the
types of programs or policies that would
allow for that to happen well as I said
I think we you know the the government
spends about 30 billion a year on jobs
training the private sector spells about
that spends about 300 billion so there
are job training programs out there by
the people who have the jobs and know
what training people need so I would if
I really wanted to get the Department of
Labor working hand in glove with the
private sector which again is something
I understood having been in the private
sector but get to get the Department of
Labor instead of trying to do its own
independent training programs you know
kind of wasting government money because
quite honestly the the programs that
Department of Labor's use in the past
have not been successful work with the
people who know what they're doing who
know where the jobs are who know when
I mean do you think from a conservative
or a libertarian point of view I mean
the companies should be training the
employees that they want it shouldn't be
costed on to the taxpayer right right
and it that's exactly right but we
should also be working to make sure that
the people people who are unemployed
people that are particularly youth in
our inner cities you know but we we have
to get this is what this was going to be
a major focus for me you know people in
the inner cities need to feel like they
have a buy into the American dream right
now they don't feel they have their
there aren't jobs in the inner city
there's interpret there's not sufficient
training for people in the inner city so
you know I you know like I said I
started out at Baskin Robbins idea one
of the proudest days in my professional
career was when the franchisee who owned
and managed that store called me in the
office and said you're now the assistant
general manager you can open in the
morning handed me a key I walked in the
next morning I think within a half an
hour that was the cleanest Baskin
Robbins in America yeah but that's the
kind of pride the kind of accomplishment
the kind of self-satisfaction that keeps
you out of gangs keeps you in your
family keeps you off the streets keeps
you in school means it allows you to
participate in the American dream if you
don't have that experience you really
don't know what it's like you really
don't know what it means so we need to
create those opportunities for
inner-city kids I mean look at Chicago
President Obama's home city it's a
disaster there's you know there are war
zones in our cities this is because
people don't feel they're part of the
process they don't feel they're part of
that they can achieve in the current
American system and we need to we got to
get rid of these progressive policies
generate economic growth create
opportunity and bring people in do you
think there's an economic mobility
crisis in the country you know I'm 53
and for as long as I can remember I keep
hearing that the next generation is the
first generation in America that will
grow up with a lower standard of living
you know than their parents and that's
never really come true is it finally
arriving or do you think that that's
kind of a hyperbolic statement
well the eight years of GDP growth of 2%
or less has created a real problem in
that risk and we call it 16 years
because it wasn't like Bush was kicking
it right no but it wasn't he didn't have
much 2% I mean we've got a president
that didn't have by the way getting back
to Larry Summers Jason Furman back in
2009 and 10
after the stimulus was invested they
were predicting 4% GDP growth 4 percent
GDP growth because they thought they
were on this economic cycle they didn't
realize there is no economic cycle if
you're not going to go up unless you
have good policies there can be a
movement there's like an up and down
like a saw maybe maybe there's a saw
economic policy but they thought they
were on the upswing and they never got
there they never got to a year of 3% GDP
growth
1% GDP growth it's like a million jobs
yeah so if you're at for your two we
said approach 2 million Jack I don't I
don't question that but I mean in the
21st century we've seen and not just in
America but especially in America both
under Bush and Obama week historically
week average economic growth you see the
same thing in Europe even in places like
China it's been slowing down is this you
know in some economists say look this
you know those glory days of two three
percent economic growth are taken for
granted are we just in a different world
now no we're not in a different world
we're in a world and in this country
we're in a world that's been dominated
by very bad economic policy in the 70s
people were saying the same thing and
then you had the incredible 80s and
right on through the 90s because you
know Clinton really had no defense
spending lower capital gains taxes I
mean you know yeah we had this really
this 20-year boom when I would take them
we need to cut active we need to cut
defense spending do it no I'm what I'm
saying is that you had the benefit of
that in the 90s I actually think I need
to increase defense spending also
stimulate it's a bad stimulus project
III don't think we need to increase it
as a stimulus project I need to I think
we need to increase it cuz we're in
trouble ok and well you know let's talk
about Donald Trump you know are you are
you happy with his performance so far
and you give him a grade and could he
you know what could he do better what is
he doing right I saying the economy I'd
give him an A+ I mean if you you look at
the economic data and an article in the
hill in June on this and in the Wall
Street Journal in May but from February
through June of this year
there are 600 20,000 more Americans
working last year under President Obama
47,000 were working there are almost a
million more people 944 thousand that
are working full-time jobs 400,000 fewer
are working part-time jobs so that whole
increase has been in people working
better full-time jobs we've seen the
jobless claims are now at
Loes we haven't seen since 1973 when
there were 68 million more people in the
employable population median household
income household net worth and job
openings are all at historic highs
they'd never been this high in fact and
on net worth were 27
there was a trillion over where we were
prior to the end of the recession so
economic and with business optimism
because people believe that President
Trump is going to reduce taxes that he's
going to deal with the health care
problem with the health insurance
problem we're seeing real business
optimism and growth people willing to
invest so on that part I'd give him a
plus he has done what he said he would
do on on regulatory rollback in terms of
regulation now this is partly and what
people say about Trump in his best
impulses it's harder to get things done
than you think and you mentioned
regulatory rollback in his budget if it
was implemented and this is from
Washington University in st. Louis
you're looking legal mater they people
at the Wyden bomb center came out with a
study saying he would it would reduce
the number of regulatory regulators at
various agencies but it would actually
increase spending in the federal
government on regulatory activity by 3%
which was something like double the
amount of Obama's last year is it is it
much more difficult than it seems to
actually roll back regulation
what's it's the problem is shrinking the
bureaucracy and I think you can see yeah
you know ever since President Wilson who
really wanted an independent bureaucracy
that would run the government kind of
independent of elected officials you've
really seen this fourth branch of
government that was created and you've
seen Trump have incredible problems with
this branch of government because you've
got a bunch of employees from the Obama
so this is the administrative state that
you look at skilling is it's strangling
this country it needs to be and we've
got a president I think we've got a
president who'd like to clean it out and
see it reduced and he will keep fighting
to do that as long as we keep him in
office okay final question you want it
to be you played in a rock and roll band
who is your favorite rock and roller
well I'd say the best guitar player and
my favorite guitar player was a guy
named Phil cagy
and he's still playing blues he's a
Christian runner stars even though he is
now when I was a kid I was going to Kent
State
we'd have one night the James Gang would
play in the local bar JB's and the next
night it'd be the glass heart so one
night you had Joe Walsh or Phil cakey
before Glenn Schwartz before I'm Glenn
Schwartz ended up in Pacific Gas and
Electric then you'd have Phil cagy the
neck so two of the best guitar players
ever you know playing in your local bar
but I thought Phil and Joe's great -
Joe's he's an incredible personality we
will leave it there we've been talking
with Andy Pusser he was a labor
secretary nominee and the former CEO of
Hardee's and Carl's jr. thanks so much
for talking - I pleasure thank you for
reason I'm Nikolas me
[Music]